one good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Wednesday it is
hump day this week there's just
something about something short special
I am joined it's very appropriate by a
girl who I would love to get my hands on
to hump oh it's this natural we humped
all weekend we did hump all weekend it
is a snatchler our little sis Margo is
joining us while Jackie is out today at
some doctor's appointments and I feel
like I feel blessed I feel blessed to be
here honestly you look gorgeous do I
tell us about your like very relaxed
cool girl summer fit you know I was
really inspired by Sophia or t Grange
you were really inspired by all the
birthday gifts you got from your
extremely generous sister 100 this shirt
lueve by my sister Olivia astray these
shoes are Mess by my sister Claudius
right and then the rest is mine but yeah
no I'm just feeling
um quiet luxury yes they're calling it
stealth wealth yeah I really am just
like loving it I should have wore my
pearls I got myself like some pearls
snatchers in like a rich woman era we're
living for it literally that I'm making
everyone else buy for me and I am
dressed like a businesswoman in the
middle of winter but that's because I am
going to a panel after this like our
outfits could not be more different well
I did wear a blazer over this because I
have to go to work after but I really
just like it wasn't about the oversized
Blazer you know such thanks for making
time and your extremely busy day for the
toasters you know the last time you were
on the toast was like somewhat recently
yeah and we had a bunch of guests that
week and I thought it was really
interesting that the most downloaded
episode belonged to the satch I would
have thought it was one of the big stars
100 I wish I thought I was me bottom of
the totem pole because like everyone
hears from me all the time you know but
not really ever since you kind of quit
your podcast I quit my job you quit your
podcast now it's like give a satch give
us action so when you come on it's
actually like a really big guest kind of
better wouldn't you say it's kind of
better so aren't you glad listen I was
never upset that you quit I wanted you
supported me whatever made you happy
yeah but now when we get you it's kind
of like we nailed an interview exclusive
with the big star big exclusive we had
such a fabulous weekend this is actually
perfect timing I want to feel happiness
like that all the time I wish I think I
said that literally yesterday and then I
said it like to like my friend yesterday
I wish for happiness like this forever
yeah was Friday night like
that was the night that Margo and I just
like Rogue a few hours before the
concert bought tickets we hadn't planned
it and we ended up having like it was
like the best night of your life right
no a thousand percent and like I can't
believe
there was a time like when we were like
thinking about us going back and forth
on whether or not to buy it and I just
like wish I could have told those girls
like just just [__] do it it was not
only the best concert of my life like
the best night of my life no duh it was
so everything like you know when things
like everything just works out yes and
as one of those things was working out
for us like from for from everything
like from the get of like once we got
the tickets it was like the car the Uber
was easy Uber was easy like the lines
for the bar and the food were lots yeah
like we ended up being did you say like
I did it oh MetLife Stadium had like
this really cool we didn't even know
when we were buying our tickets that one
of the the section that we were in had
its own like Club so in terms of like
bathroom bar and food it was like this
little club for only people in our
section it was like so premium so
premium there were no lines you have to
like go upstairs like when you enter
MetLife stadiums like we literally just
like entered on the floor or walked into
our club walked into our club and it was
like so like Lux what's the word like um
Humane it was so civilized yeah
civilized
um so that that just made it like so
much better also because like I don't I
don't drink water like I never have to
pee I peed six times on Friday night
like I don't know what it was I think I
was like nervous or like overwhelmed but
it was fine because the bathroom was
like two steps behind us and there was
no line so like literally Taylor would
like start talking in between songs one
of us would run to the bathroom the
other one would watch our stuff yeah and
we would get back from the bathroom
she'd still be talking she'd still be
talking and that's because a Taylor
talks slot and B um let's just be honest
we did not wash our hands no I'm sorry I
can't be bothered to do that I also had
a 13 on my hand that I had written in
makeup so if I'd started washing my
hands every time I peed like it would
have been gone no I just like there's no
you don't have to give an excuse we
don't have to explain ourselves like as
to why we didn't wash our hands no like
I took a shower when I got home but yeah
of course I didn't wash my hands once at
the concert and I'm not even ashamed no
I watched him the first time we went and
then that was it I was not gonna keep
watching I'm gonna keep being here
um let's see with such what's a massage
um give us a little update into the life
of a fabulous touch summer's coming up I
feel like you're always like doing
fabulous things in the summer I do have
I do have a lot coming up but not as not
that that much like um this weekend I
have a wedding in Toronto beautiful
beautiful and then me Emily and Ryan are
doing our camping trip yeah in two weeks
um we're going to Yellowstone Montana do
you guys remember at the beginning of
the year when Jackie and I were talking
about oh God you brought this up um when
Jack and I were talking about like our
goals for the year and I said like I
want to take a few big trips and
honestly we're halfway through the year
and I've made no progress on any of them
wait that such a lie we went to Belize
you went to Portugal Belize was last
year okay no Portugal was this year but
I said I wanted to go to like London or
Paris and then Montana
um and I was just kind of talking about
like one of my dreams is to go to
Montana and then Margot just kind of
kind of just mentioned really briefly
and quietly that she was going to
Montana this summer okay for the record
I literally said that you could come but
if you don't want to go to Montana the
way that I am going to Montana I know
they're like sleeping on the ground yeah
we're like sleeping in a tent it's like
a nice tent but like let's be real here
you wouldn't want to do that no I would
never do that but like maybe if you had
included me in some of the planning
talks like we could have found a
beautiful you know hotel we don't that
we don't want to you're such a freak
like Yeah I'm such a freak but also like
it was just like next level like last
year like being connected with nature
like does your like Facility have a
toilet yes there's a toilet and a shower
in the tent and is the toilet like a
hole in the ground not a hole in the
ground it is a toilet with plumbing yes
but we don't do number two in that you
don't no like last year what we did and
well so last year like all three of us
shared a tent like me Emily and Ryan so
it's like it's tight but this year we
got two separate ones so Ryan can sleep
on his own so maybe we'll make that one
the poopy Ted oh that's smart but what
we did last year was just Pete in ours
and then went to like the main lobby
tent and like those were like legit ass
bathrooms and that's where we would do
our business so like if you had like you
know a big meal and you're laying in bed
and then you had to run to walk up to
the tent as if was it far yeah yeah I
could never exude self-control like that
I don't have like really good control
over my bowels like my bowels run my
life I don't run my battles I mean High
me too but I feel like in occasions like
that like your body just knows when to
participate that's true also when you
travel like you just poop less yeah but
sometimes your body will really work
with you yeah so I'm just like praying
for that but I'm a big lately like runs
in the middle of the night so like
hopefully we don't have that scenario
situation um but if I do I will figure
it out just stick to the BRAT diet
things that kind of bind you up yeah but
the thing is is like you kind of have to
just take what you can get when it comes
to food there oh you know it's not like
it's not like well maybe if we stayed at
my hotel we'd have a gorgeous Buffet
right I understand but we're the point
of it is to be like rustic and Camp no I
get it I feel like the hotel that I
would stay at is like extremely rustic
okay for sure I feel like they
definitely have you know you are more
than welcome to come there we have a
space for one more person we can kick
emulate it with Ryan we can stay with me
in the town and then what like
activities are you planning like like
hikes and stuff yeah we're hiking oh man
horseback riding oh okay fly fishing fun
um we're doing like a river float up
success like you don't have to paddle
you just sit I think so like this like
Wildlife tour cool
um and then we're seeing like the old
geezer you know how that's like you know
it sounds familiar for me oh sorry Old
Faithful whatever I don't know there's
some stuff to see in Yellowstone but for
the most part yeah we'll be like hiking
in the Yellowstone National Park oh
you're right into the national park
that's where under canvas is oh that's
actually really cool yeah and like the
views are crazy yeah
I don't know yeah you still wouldn't do
it but it's cool like you see why one
would no I totally get the Allure but
for me like I find like room service and
Spas like so alone yeah there's none of
that there's an ABC oh oh and also
there's no Chargers so it's like there's
like just like charging boxes everywhere
like they have a million but like it's
not like there's like Outlets
and you pay for that experience that's
what people do because I'm working with
under canvas no but like the people like
they pay for to be tortured like that
but it's not torture like they really do
make it as like Glam as possible yeah
like where are you supposed to get an
outlet in the middle of the desert at my
hotel
right my hotel has outlets they have
buffets they have Spas they have room
service I just feel like but can you see
the stars probably probably you probably
could see the stars from my hotel um
okay I'm just saying like think about it
I'll think about it I mean it's booked I
know I know ready to go um so just like
another fabulous summer being counselor
since yeah but then after that which is
in two weeks I have no other trips
planned yeah we didn't plan a lot of
trips this summer obviously because
we're on Bebe watch
um which is fine yeah
that's fine also like we can if we like
we're dying to go somewhere for a
weekend like you can just we can pick up
last minute yeah yeah
um well so are you excited to join me
here at the shows like what are you what
have you been into recently like in
terms of Pop Culture that's such a good
question we've like such different
interests I do have to say as someone
who does not watch Bravo or anything I
have been like sucked into the Scandal
yeah like I haven't watched anything but
I've watched like anytime there's like a
reunion clip or a season finale clip on
my Tick Tock like I watch it multiple
times interesting um because I just find
it to be like so interesting because I
literally can't believe like someone
like Tom Sandoval exists I know it's
really crazy to me like I honestly I
want to be as delusional as him no it's
actually inspiring inspiring the levels
of unwell he is like to not give a [__]
about also anyone or anything in your
life like that's an achievement have we
heard from Rachel no like not was she on
the reunion yeah she was like watching
in the back so there's three parts of
the reunion part two is on tonight oh
and I think we might hear from her
tonight she we didn't have hear from her
in part one because before the reunion
she filed a restraining order against
Sheena because she alleged that Sheena
punched her and Sheena was like I just
shoved her
um and so she has to sit in a trailer
100 yards away watching everyone and
then Sheena will leave and Raquel will
replace her yeah it was actually a
pretty smart move yeah because then they
had to like re-jigger the whole Reunion
yeah so no we haven't heard is she mean
cast member Rachel she wasn't that's the
thing I heard Andy on a podcast talking
about this like she's always been
James's girlfriend and the other girls
that thought she was Dumb and really
never brought her into the fold and then
this season she starts becoming friends
with like a lot of the main characters
and and it definitely got to her head in
a way of being you know one of the first
people that production was like oh we
got him Raquel like she became what I
think she really wanted to be for so
many years and I think maybe she got
carried away yeah 100 that's definitely
part of it but up until this point no
she was never ever like is she in the
intro yes but they have everyone in the
intro they have like Lisa's son who's
literally never on the show okay fine I
love everyone also what I've been um
sucked into was the Summer House reunion
oh you know what I don't watch but I
also got sucked into the Summer House
reunion I started watching the season at
the beginning and it just was bad and I
and I was not like entranced at all but
there were clips of The Reunion are all
over my Tick Tock too and also like I
just love Paige and I loved her outfit I
loved her outfit and so I was really um
wanting to see what the girlies were up
to and it seems extremely contentious it
does seem extremely contentious between
Lindsay and Paige and I've always like
I've never been on Lindsay's side I've
always felt like where is the Reckoning
of Lindsay Hubbard like she was always
acting like such an animal and then this
year they decided to have the Reckoning
yeah but I didn't really felt like she
was doing it because it reckoned no she
didn't deserve it like oh if anything
this is the first season she's acting so
mature she's in like a really healthy
relationship she stopped drinking so I'm
like why are we all coming for her now
not in her toxic years you know what I
mean literally like I have no idea what
I'm talking about but I should know in
the few episodes that I've watched like
I've wanted a reckoning for Kyle
oh by the way Kyle like if you go back
and watch it now there's like this whole
movement on Tick Tock it's like well
Justice for Hannah burner yes I saw that
I saw that Hannah burner two years ago
like really they they pushed her off the
show and a lot of it had to do with Kyle
right and Kyle is kind of like
like a puppeteer almost he like because
he's boy he doesn't really get in the
weeds but he's definitely like a part of
something no yeah yeah and I agree I I
think that there's a reckoning for Kyle
coming up yeah but like it's too late
now because he's married to Amanda yeah
and so like they're a team and Amanda's
friends with all the girls so they won't
it's it's tough It's Complicated
Dynamics for sure for sure
um well I think we're gonna dive in
because we have a lot to do today we
have the Fast Five and we have deer
toaster so we're gonna get some good
some good advice from this hatch I love
to give advice that I don't follow I
know and some of the submissions share
about people with kids like you and I
quite literally knowing nothing quite
literally knowing nothing but at least
you can change a diaper yeah I feel like
we can handle it counts I think so when
do you think you're gonna change your
first diaper when I have a kid so you
don't love okay
does it have to do with love also for
the record when we were recording the
redheads beforehand Dana had brought up
she was like cracking up from that part
and Brit and Dana were both like we've
never changed a diaper either like that
is not Auntie Duty it is due date first
of all it is like when you're
sister is in a bind like you help out
and you change a diaper like that's love
that's love for sure I just I maybe I'm
gonna pee you would change a pita I
could change a p i could change a p i
could change a p but not the Poo the I
like
it really like I understand
um well let's just say that I'm the
number one auntie in this group how does
that sound if that's if that's what you
need to continue changing them while I
watch you are the number one answer you
need yeah and you are the number one
auntie in this group well the number one
and number two aunties in the street
were about to deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know and
today's episode is brought to you by
Court life is always changing and your
furniture should be able to change with
it with court furniture rental you can
get the furniture and services that you
need that help make every life
transition as seamless as possible so
whether you're making a short-term
long-distance move relocating starting a
new chapter or you simply don't want to
be tied down to owning Furniture court
has a solution for you simply pick the
furniture you want then their expert
team delivers and sets it up the
furniture will be there when you need it
and gone when you don't you can get
furniture on your own terms with court
furniture rental visit court.com podcast
to learn more and find the furniture
package that fits your life so you can
really have everything in this life on
demand and now thanks to court you can
have furniture on demand I feel like
this is so smart one be because like
Furniture Trends are always changing so
to invest so much money in like a couch
that really might not be cool in two
years is such a waste of money a lot of
people don't like to be tied down they
want to live a kind of Carefree sporadic
spontaneous life and court allows that
if you're moving short term like hey I
want to try out Montana for the Year let
me get some furniture for my tent okay
it's really a fabulous service and I
think a lot more people need to know
about it you can make room for something
new without leaving a mess behind to
clean up Court will pick up what you've
rented Without You lifting a finger and
by renting of course you're supporting a
more sustainable way of living so visit
court.com podcast that's
c-o-r-t.com slash podcast to learn more
and find the furniture package that fits
your needs today's episode is also
brought to you by seed I love seed this
morning yep you did yes and how are how
are you feeling like in terms of the
benefits so I've received like I've
started taking it like every single day
and I've found that my like
bowels are scheduled like scheduled and
firm
um and I just felt like I was like I
should be taking it's a Prebiotic
antibiotic right so it's like I really
should be taking those things so I was
just like let me start taking seed and
it really like I just I feel so much
more regular so see it's ds01 daily
symbiotic is a plant-based Prebiotic and
probiotic with a 24 strain that has been
clinically or scientifically studied for
its benefits so it's free from 14
allergens like um
The efca Authority that are defined by
The efca Authority it's also sugar-free
vegan soy-free Sesame free gluten-free
peanut free ampa free dairy-free
shellfish free corn free how it works is
that you'll take two capsules once a day
on an empty stomach so that could be the
first thing in the morning or two hours
after your last meal and it's engineered
to survive your external and internal
environments so their capsule and
capsule VI cap safeguards viability
through digestion for a delivery of an
average of 100 of their probiotic
starting dose to your colon so a lot of
times you'll take a probiotic and it
won't work that's because it literally
does not survive your digestive check
but like seed they got you covered it's
making it all the way so there's a lot
of benefits there's also a lot of skin
benefits but a lot of people you know
are taking it for Digestive to become
more regular more solid as you said
counts thank you so
um you can avoid gut media head to try
head to the trusted source for
symbiotics start a new healthy habit
when you visit seed.com toast and use
code toast to redeem 30 off your first
month of seeds ds01 daily symbiotic
that's seedseed.com toast and use code
toast our accounts ready to dive into
the Fast Five I am all right first story
like took the World by storm yesterday
about Al Pacino oh yeah I saw this
everywhere our 82 year old 82 year old
King is expecting a baby with his
girlfriend nor alfala and why is that
interesting because she's 29 years old
so the 82 year old actor and his
girlfriend Nora alfala are expecting a
baby his rep has confirmed to people
she's been linked to Al Pacino since uh
April 2022 so that's a little bit over a
year
um and they share a daughter already the
New York I'm sorry the New York native
shares a daughter uh Julie Marie
who's 33 his daughter
um with his ex-girlfriend
Al Pacino already has a daughter with
with his ex-girlfriend named Julie Marie
who's 33 and he's having so Al Pacino
shares daughter Julie Marie
who's 33 with his ex-girlfriend Jan
that's what I just said no the the
ex-girlfriend's name is Jan not Julie
the daughter's name I know that's what
I'm saying you said the opposite he also
shares 22 year old twins oh wow Anton
and Olivia with his ex Beverly D'Angelo
who he dated for six years in the late
90s so that's just interesting that his
daughter Julie Marie is 33 while his
girlfriend now like this happens a lot
in Hollywood it does but like this is an
extreme version for sure and I'm I just
can't imagine at 82 you want to be
changing diapers he's not gonna be I
know I mean this is so crazy I just
think it's like I think it's crazy and
but I think like more kids in the world
the better but like sure I guess I don't
know it's just like I always get sad
when I think about it because it's like
how much longer how much longer do you
have and then the kid doesn't have a dad
and that's someone who
no it's such a good point so glad you
brought that up it's also disgusting
yeah like an 82 year old having sex with
a 29 year old like I could vomit how do
you still have sex at 82. that's an
amazing question I think for a man it's
much easier really I because it's kind
of up to the man it is up to the mail
pun intended but if I'm
remembering this correctly you know
menopause like you know you get very dry
yeah so yeah but there's like things
lubricants yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes
I don't know how you do it but clearly
Al Pacino's you know unless he just like
pills there's also pills yeah unless he
just like lays there and Cialis what's
Cialis like Viagra oh yeah yeah you know
the commercial that the two people in
the bathtubs on the beach no that's
Cialis there's just so many you know
useful big Pharma modern medicine
medicine is amazing I'm just like really
grossed out yeah no I think it's
incredibly like it's gross
um wishing them a lot of muzzle
and yeah I wonder how Julie the 33 year
old daughter feels I mean I I just fine
like I would love to know about more of
those family Dynamics like that like
also like especially in Hollywood like
there's so many weird things and
connections and I'm like are we all just
pretending this is fine or does
everybody hate each other no they're all
just pretending it's fine because when
you live in L.A and like everyone around
you is doing like weird things it just
becomes normalized right right like I
don't think anybody in La thinks this is
weird but like we do yeah that's insane
it's really gross
um he spoke to the New Yorker about
fatherhood in 2014 saying I'm
responsible to them I'm part of their
life when I'm not It's upsetting to me
and to them so that's part of the
Gestalt and I get a lot of it I get a
lot from it it takes it takes you out of
yourself so he loves being a dad clearly
I would hope so because I would hope so
he's banging him out because he's got
quite a few and he's going to been doing
it until the day he dies so true so
wishing Al and nor a life a lifetime of
happiness and you know good luck in her
pregnancy on this journey our next story
is the sweetest thing ever I don't know
if you saw that Drew Barrymore went to
the eras tour and she is gushing over
Taylor Swift after attending the tour
with her daughter she says I cried so
hard so she posted a picture of her kids
like a carousel yeah appeared as so she
wasn't in the tent I know like she kind
of bought her own floor seats we love to
see a queen supporting Queen and she
wrote this really long era's caption
that was so
really
um beautiful yeah and I actually like
reminded me of how I felt yeah after the
concert and if Instagram could load I
would read the caption for you
sorry Jackie usually does this so just
give me a minute the iPad
is not working with me Drew Barrymore
I'm just trying to pull up her Instagram
like is that so hard do you want me to
pull it up on my phone no Grandma can do
it sorry this page isn't available okay
I'm gonna pull it up
okay this page isn't available what is
going on I'm literally a grandma
I just want to read
her [__] caption
Drew okay got it thank you pass oh you
want me to read it no no I want to read
it are you sure yeah yeah oh okay
because I thought it was like really
sweet and like I want to remind myself
ready at Taylor Swift I cried so hard
when you sing Welcome to New York I
moved here not knowing where my life was
going and I actually found myself so
happy in this chapter I also cried
watching my daughters and cousin Sadie
watch and love and sing to someone so
admirable you caps caps I love you
Taylor Swift with like 10 exclamation
points you are the role model all of us
girls and women need thank you for one
of the best nights of Our Lives we are
so lucky to have seen your show you're
also giving three hour show P.S we
listen to on vinyl every morning to get
ready for our day you transcend and make
life beautiful everyone passing beaded
bracelets around witnessing the good
it's true yeah literally first of all I
loved Drew Barrymore like everyone makes
fun of her because she's like so emo and
like sitting on the floor sitting on the
floor with people and like touching
eyelids with people but she really is
just like um big kids and so much love
to give she's really like a lovely
person and I love this caption I love
that you went to the concert I love that
she like knew she like knew about Taylor
like she also like she gave Justice for
Welcome to New York a little bit right
even though people were not and Drew
Barrymore only moved to New York
recently for her show right and so I
think like she wasn't talking about how
this song You Know helped her as a kid
she was talking about how it helped her
as an adult and I thought that was
really sweet no really sweet and like I
just I like living for all the
celebrities going to Taylor let's talk
about that I have so many questions
about logistics oh of course but I feel
like there was you know a time when like
so many celebrities were like
not afraid but just like anti-taylor a
little bit and like there's been so many
celebrities who have like spoken out
against Taylor because for so long it
was just like the thing that people did
right of course they like made fun of
her and so I I know now and I feel like
she wrote about this when she wrote that
wrote that essay like 30 things I
learned when I was 30.
um like she doesn't seek validation from
like Hollywood or celebrities and it has
to feel good but I I think that she
doesn't care I think she really cares
about like the fans so it it's a little
like no for sure and I know I'm just
like so confused by like some of the
people popping up like I feel like
there's people that are like obviously
like core Taylor yeah of course the
tellers Marisha Hargitay Gigi Hadid Hoda
yeah Hoda yeah I feel like Hoda is like
that's because she always goes on GMA
yeah I just feel no GMA is not Hoda
Hoda's Today Show oh I just feel like
Hoda's like I don't know I just I feel
like Cody's like a nice person who's
like always been friends with Taylor I
can't explain it I have no proof okay
sure but then like I feel like I just
Bradley Cooper random random Julia
Garner Paul Rudd Paul Rudd lin-manuel I
think they did cats together I think
lin-manuel was like involved in cats oh
so it's just like confusing to me and
then also
how like how does one get in the ten
like say you're like A-list celeb not
even A-list but whatever and what do you
do right I think you can't just like
call Taylor up no you call tree up
Taylor's publicist hey I want to be in
the tent yeah and I think Taylor's
pretty open I mean we were talking when
we were at the show we sat right behind
the VIP tent and we saw Molly Ringwald
which we thought was like an interesting
that was an interesting one right so I
think they're pretty you know Lacks also
I saw a video of Andrea Swift and
because she's in the family Town she's
in a separate tent and I think Michael
Strahan was in the family tent
interesting because someone was like how
the [__] did you get this video so close
it was like you had to be in the tent
and someone commented like the girl
she's with is with Michael Strahan's
daughter
interesting that's very interesting
right like was the friend's tent
overflowing and they I I do think that
the friends tent like this this weekend
was like definitely packed also they
have snacks did you see that what yes it
was in someone's video
um emrata like of course and in the
background of it was like snacks and
food like catering you know what that
makes sense yeah of course what they're
gonna keep going back and forth I also
saw there was a couch is there yeah
which I thought was interesting but you
could Lounge on the couch right but
there was a couch maybe it was for Kelly
Taylor because Kelly Taylor did show up
in a wheelchair yes you did she like she
broke her foot or something but I think
I think I saw someone hoist her up and
she just like stood in place yeah not
even a broken foot could I mean how
could you could stop to sit during the
Taylor Swift concert is couldn't be us
couldn't be us couldn't be us we only
sad between eras because someone
actually DM me that before we went to
the first show they were like hot like
Pro tips sit between every era or else
like you're not going to be okay and we
do that very literally no we really
recharged between every era yeah
um
I just love Drew Barrymore I really I
mean like my Drew Barrymore era I feel
like she's like
people are really
um
so much of her stuff like goes viral now
it's all due to like her talk show and I
just feel like it's having a really good
effect on like her reputation and she
just seems like a really sweet lady she
really does her and Kelly Clarkson like
the doing like show those TV show TV
shows like I you would think is where
your career like kind of goes to stalls
but it didn't I feel like it's giving
them a new life no between Kelly okay I
mean Kelly Okie is just like next level
and then Drew Barrymore is like really
unique interview style I think both
women are kind of like taking the
industry by storm I couldn't agree more
and I'm really happy for them and I love
to see it me too we gotta get on there
we go would you rather go on Kelly
Clarkson show or do rally Kelly Clarkson
okay I just said I thought I'd ask come
on have you ever seen an episode of the
toast no I know I just wanted to throw
it out mostly because I would make Kelly
sing with me
some people wait a lifetime
for a moment even though I think she's
like probably over singing that song
probably you should ever sing toast see
stop I feel like she would Andy Grammer
sang toast when he came on the toast I
love him I love him too
um okay ready for our next story yeah
some really kind of disgusting
Royal news you've not believed what
they've done this time what Prince
George has been forced to do chores by
Prince William and Kate Middleton no
[__] way so in remarks that
resurfaced this week Kate Middleton
revealed that she expects her children
to do chores especially during school
breaks while visiting a goat farm in
Wales last year Middleton shared that
Prince George's chore after Prince wait
Middleton shared Prince George's chore
after Prince William pointed out a robot
silage sweeper so she says that was
George's job at half term moving feed
they added that their three children
were learning how to get involved in the
farm at their Sandringham estate
sandring him we're trying some
agroforestry as well William added
according to the outlet I don't
understand anything that is being said
so basically they have a farm and when
the kids are on break they make them
work the farm for like a minute and I
think this is their attempt at like
being real with us they're not doing a
really good job yeah because we don't
have Farms also like no one is expecting
them like you saying that they're doing
chores like I automatically don't
believe you like no one's expecting them
to do chores no they're also saying that
they do chores when they're like on
vacation right not like when they're in
school it's not like a regular thing
they do chores only when they're on
school break right
like have him take out the trash yeah
the thing is like I just can't see it no
same it's not
it's not Computing their kids are so
cute though they really are I feel like
I just recently saw new photos that like
um The Palace release like the portraits
yeah they're so cute no they do it like
the the youngest one Louie is that his
name
I'm really like never remember I believe
it is I know there's George there's
George Charlotte and Louie yeah yeah
yeah yeah he's a cutie and Charlotte is
like a carbon copy of Kate I know it's
really cute um I feel like also the pr
team or like the social media team for
the family of William Kane yeah I forget
what they're called I think they're
called Kensington Royal oh
um they do a very good job on social
media yeah they do like they put Kate on
like a mom podcast like they do a good
job of releasing portraits and they have
like and they're not like these old
stuffy like Royal portraits they look
like they're having fun no they look
like portraits like people on The
Bachelor like run into a field and take
you know yeah they're like very
millennially very instagramming they do
a really good job yeah how does one get
that job I feel like it's actually like
a really not fun stressful job for sure
are you kidding no like every amount of
like approvals you probably have to go
through I like the amount of times you
have to read your caption before you
post it making sure you're not posting
on your own account yeah I mean like
remember when the Pope's social media
account accidentally liked like like
three photos from a only fans model no
yeah it was like clearly like one or
social media one of the archbishops like
social media people just was on like
thought he was on his own account that's
frightening and they did a whole
investigation they couldn't find how
they mysteriously liked this photo oh my
gosh but like it was the official
Vatican yeah yeah yeah it was
humiliating see that's why the follow
what the ex what was that page called
the following page the following page
yeah that's why but I loved that thing
wait I didn't even get an update on
Instagram yesterday ginormous Instagram
stories yes they made the circles that
you tap for everyone's stories [__]
huge yeah I don't know why it's like
half the screen now I don't dislike it
me neither I mean I really go to stories
first regardless always I never scroll
my feed I scroll my feet if I'm really
bored yeah but I'm like always watching
People's stories it's so interesting to
me me too I'm like when I realized I'm
like posted six seconds ago I'm like you
gotta stop no and like it's really weird
because when you first start following
someone their stories like come to the
front of your feed and it's like so
embarrassing because then they think
they're like oh this person just
followed me and she's obsessed with me
so like I had that like what like I
recently started falling Brandon charnis
okay and literally his stories come up
first in my thing so I'm like I just
looked because like whatever yeah and
quite literally he probably thinks I'm
like stalking it Mario they always come
up first I don't know why so now do you
like actively avoid no I'm not ashamed
like I'm I'm not talking it's just what
the algorithm is feeding me a thousand
percent but it's humiliating yeah it is
humiliating oh my God if I just spent
like less time on my phone I wouldn't
have these problems as possible but we
all know that ain't gonna happen stats
ain't gonna happen we have two more
stories and then we're gonna do deer
toasters but the two more stories are
brought to you by Squarespace I know you
were like is this brought to you by
Squarespace Virgo they are brought to
you by Squarespace okay okay so whatever
you are looking to start a website for
whether you want to get into blogging
you want to start a podcast there's a
million reasons why and Squarespace is
really the place to go to sell anything
so they have the tools that you need to
get your business off the ground
including e-commerce templates Inventory
management a simple checkout process
secure payments so whatever you want to
do whether you want to create an
e-commerce website whatever you want to
sell Squarespace has merchandising
features that make your products look
their best online you can connect with
your audience and generate Revenue
through gated members only content you
can manage your members send email
Communications and leverage audience
insights all in one easy to use platform
so head to squarespace.com toast for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch use offer code toast you'll save
10 off your first purchase of a website
or a domain so there's a million reasons
you could want to start a website and
there's also a million tools that
Squarespace offers that might be
beneficial for whatever you're getting
into so they have great ways to connect
your social media accounts they offer
really good traffic overview so it's
basically seeing how your visits unique
visitors page views Etc are trending
over time you'll get insight into the
top traffic sources what I really like
about Squarespace is the content
ownership so you own all of the content
that you put on the Squarespace platform
they just offer a one-click data
portability so again check out
squarespace.com toast for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch use
offer code toast to save 10 off your
first purchase of a website or a domain
today's episode is also brought to you
by the perfect bar we actually just got
a shipment when I walked in I saw the
Box this episode is brought to you by
the perfect bar the original
refrigerated protein bar that you know
and love if you haven't heard perfect
bar just launched a new line of protein
bars called the perfect bar layers
perfect bar layers are a new line of
crispy protein snack stacked with three
delicious layers and are packed with
whole food nutrition they're made with a
crispy base of peanut and cashew butter
they're layered with dark chocolate or
100 real fruit and then they're
sprinkled with toasted gluten-free oats
they're packed with up to 11 grams of
protein and they come in two delicious
flavors crispy peanut butter and
chocolate crispy peanut butter and Berry
they're basically just like a healthy
peanut butter and jelly they're so good
they really keep you full for a long
period of time it's I actually have one
in my purse because I have the longest
day today like being a businesswoman
like you know crushing deals crunching
numbers and having one in my purse we
keep them at the studio too I also have
them at home it's just so good to have
because they really keep you full
they're super delicious and they're made
with whole food ingredients because
they're kept in the fridge and then it
makes you question like all the other
bars sitting in your cabinets for months
disgusting disgusting literally
disgusting they are non-GMO project
verified gluten-free soy-free kosher and
low GI and the best part is that you can
now find them in the refrigerated
section at Target Nationwide so perfect
bar knows that it'll be Love At First
Bite so they're offering you a chance to
try their new refrigerated protein bars
for free sign up for email or text and
upload a picture of your receipt from
your local grocery store and they'll
reimburse you for the cost of one bar
it'll go directly into your venmower
PayPal account all you have to do is go
to perfect snacks.com toast to get a
free perfect bar today that's perfect
snacks.com toast to get a free perfect
bar today happy snacking happy snacking
okay we've got some Dating News oh but
like not it's not what you think Raven
Simone Oh is speaking out about her
dating life and saying everyone she's
ever dated had to sign an NDA
interesting I wonder if that's like the
norm yeah she opened up on the Howie
Mandel uh podcast which was the scene of
the crime for Tom Sandoval about what
dating has entailed for her as a Disney
star before she married her wife she
said all of my relationships especially
obviously when I started dating I had to
get people to sign ndas it took me a
while to wrap my head around it because
it's very impersonal but someone in our
position needs to do that it's true when
she was asked when she at what point she
presents the paperwork she answered
before the naughty time comes so before
they have sex oh she said no I'm serious
right before that like she'd go on like
six dates with some and not have sex
with them and they wouldn't sign an NDA
but I guess if things are getting like
steamy she literally has to like open up
her file cabinet and it's like wait hold
that thought and fetch fetch your
paperwork and her notary she says
welcome to being a celebrity in
Hollywood these days it's true though
nowadays hashtags real life they change
the dynamic of having an intimate
relationship with somebody as for when
she asked her now wife to sign in NDA
the actress recalled that that moment
was crazy it came almost two months into
seeing each other we were in New York we
were in this outdoor French type of
restaurant and my mom had been bugging
me about it you got to get it signed you
got to get it signed and I'm like she's
from the industry and my mom was just
bugging me so I was really reluctant
because I knew something was different
about Miranda she's like I don't
understand because
she knew that we had something different
like it just felt different right and so
when she presented presented it
um
the girlfriend her now wife was
understanding because she could tell
that Raven was being pushed to do this
by someone else or someone else
um I mean that's horrible I just want to
say like but I feel like everybody does
that I can't remember who I feel like I
heard this about too I don't remember
but it was like someone who's like I
think it was a man
and like every girl that they have sex
with has to sign an NDA well it's like a
one night stand there's that thing about
Kris Jenner that like literally everyone
who enters their home before she even
like in her foyer there's a stack of
ndas that everybody has to sign that's
like an old rumor and I actually think
Kris Jenner um
spoke on it was like yeah it's true like
by the way a hundred percent yeah like
that makes total sense to me no but that
also just must be horrible
um
to live like that why because you can't
trust anyone yeah yeah and like when it
comes to dating like that's yeah and I
find it interesting that she um
has them sign it before they have sex
because we forget like Raven is a Disney
Queen like she's still on Disney Raven's
home so she has to have like a really
kind of
Perfect Image yeah that's true and
maybe she's into some freaky [__] for
sure and that's okay I saw it and this
is a complete tangent I love but I saw
this video of Andy Cohen and he was
talking about the Kardashians Reunion
yeah and how like it was so [__]
juicy but like all that got cut out yeah
and he was like if I ever got a cutter
director's cut like yeah it would be
like crazy [__] and in my head I'm like
why are you even saying that I know it's
like I feel like now like the
Kardashians are gonna be like mad yeah I
thought that was so weird I thought it
was like a like a bad call on his part
to say that yeah yeah I agree I just
thought that was so but what I thought I
remember he was like it doesn't matter
because they own it all right and I'm
just like but I remember the Kardashians
reunion that Andy hosted and I actually
thought it was pretty decent yeah no it
was like decently juicy yeah but knowing
that it could have been more like now it
felt like a waste of time 100
um also have you ever signed an NDA
yeah like for brands for work yeah like
that doesn't count but I mean like no
have you I don't think so no one's ever
like made me sign one before walking
into a party or whatever no no maybe I'm
just not getting ready to the right
parties for I mean I'm definitely not um
yeah no I'm definitely not
um but
are you watching Kardashians I am did
you watch episode I watched episode one
um new episode comes out tonight or like
tomorrow oh it's Wednesday it's like
midnight whatever oh yeah
um I am watching it I thought the first
episode was really good I'm like really
interested in this Dolce Gabbana thing
me too like that's like a weird fight
like I need to know more it's so Niche
obviously I know but like
I mean I'm kind of team kid duh yeah and
did you see did you watch the first
episode yeah I did and did you see Chris
like gassing her up to do it for sure
also the fact that she even thought like
I shouldn't like I might not do it
because of Courtney and then everyone
around her saying like you should right
she's gonna do it also wasn't it months
I need better like time she said um by
the time the show comes out it will be
like five months after the wedding and
by the time the collection like hit
stores it'll be like 10 months yeah so
but what I thought was interesting from
that first episode that we learned and
this is what me and Jackie spoke about
is that the family's relationship to
Dolce Gabbana is through Chris yeah it's
Chris's relationship so if anyone has
anything to say it's Chris and the fact
that Chris sanctioned it means it's okay
agreed totally right so I look for I'm
gonna hear Courtney out but I'm just
like never on Courtney I was gonna say
I'm never on Courtney's side I just feel
like I just feel like she like hates her
sisters I feel like she hates her life
and like hates her job and like the only
thing she wants to do is like lay in bed
with Travis yeah and like take her kids
to school which is a valid life if you
want to do that but like stop what going
on TV because also it's like if this is
the first time she was saying all this
fine but we've been hearing it for years
I know and it's like the same thread I
felt like maybe in this the Hulu show
like things would be different but it's
definitely like the way she feels yeah
so it's like it's so she had her get off
the Pod no we have to hear about your
boundaries again it's like my God so put
them up go yeah go I agree
um okay you ready for our fifth and
final story I am this is like a little
steady because I'm not gonna lie the
stories were [__] horrible today you
guys I apologize but this is like a
little human interest news that I found
interesting a report on the New York
Post that 40 of restaurant food
poisoning outbreaks are caused by sick
employees
that's disgusting so sick restaurant
employees are responsible for about 40
of food poisoning outbreaks with known
causes between 2017 and 2019 so the CDC
did like a whole study on it of the 800
outbreaks reviewed by the CDC and uh of
the CDC from 875 restaurants during the
span no role virus and salmonella were
the most common causes got it so while
85 of restaurants claim to have policies
restricting sick staff from working only
16 of the policies detailed what
symptoms should require workers to call
out sick including vomiting diarrhea and
sore throat with fever so the CDC
investigators have called for better
enforcement on comprehensive food safety
policies which emphasize basic measures
like hand washing in addition to keeping
workers who are feeling under the
weather at home so that's just so crazy
well I was going to say and also the
reason I was on my phone I will Circle
back on that in a second but also I feel
like people people don't want to work
sick it's about their management right
like they feel like they have to come in
but also did you see that story in the
New York Times about how they
interviewed like 15 um
um what's it called Airline flight
attendants yeah and it's like the they
came back with like 10 hard facts about
how you should act on a plane no and I
want to go through it and I'm just I'm
trying to find it it's on the New York
Times Instagram okay in the meantime let
me just say I feel like whenever people
like get food poisoning from a
restaurant they just assume they have
bad food
right that's like your assumption not
that like the person who made it is sick
yeah yeah it makes it look kind of like
even grosser yeah of course
no and like then now I'm just I need to
know where I got the notavirus I know I
got it from Ben but like where did Ben
get it from
and every time I start to feel like a
little nauseous whether I'm like in the
back every time I'm like having like um
when I got the notovirus did you get it
no I somehow did not it was like you
Jackie Zach Ben yeah
um but every time like I'm having like
an episode I'm like please let this be a
one-time thing like no I quite literally
like every time I feel a little bit off
I'm like I live in fear constant fear
that I'm gonna get the Norovirus me too
okay ready yes a flight attendant's
etiquette rule so basically the New York
Times spoke to one flight attendant who
shared 12 Airline etiquette rules which
aim to strike a balance between your own
reasonable Comforts and thoughtfulness
to those around you okay number one keep
your socks on of course if it's a long
flight by all means relax and take off
your shoes but there's never a reason to
take off your socks keep your feet to
yourself duh for sure
no one wants to hear your FaceTime
conversation we don't need to hear both
sides of that conversation boarding an
airplane is is not the time for your
goodbyes it's time for you to
concentrate on finding your seat and
selling your bags as fast as possible
you know just like putting headphones
it's really not that hard yes okay this
is interesting everyone has the right to
recline but there's a polite way to do
it I don't agree be aware of your
surroundings before reclining peek
behind you and see what the situation is
and nicely ask if that person Minds I am
very anti-recline I'm pretty Pro recline
if the person in front of me reclines
I'm allowed to recline I know
but the thing is is like there's always
going to be
somebody who can't recline whether it's
like they're in the last row the person
behind them has really big needs and
it's like please don't like someone's
really tall there's a baby or like a car
seat so there's there's like a couple
people on the plane who can't recline
for whatever reason and so for them like
I I just don't feel like chairs on
airplanes should recline and I know this
is like a thought a hot take that not
everyone agrees with Brian thinks I'm
crazy I do not think you should recline
because even me leaning all the way back
and then someone's chair being in my
[__] like that's not comfortable okay
but I'm saying if the chair in front of
you has reclined you will stay up right
no then I'll recline right but like I
just wish the person [__] in front of
me wouldn't recline okay fair but like
my my stance is if the person in front
of me has reclined I will recline I just
I think reclining is inhumane like I'm
so against it I think that they should
take it out I don't think that it's fair
I understand and then it's really not
fair for the person who gets the seat in
the first row because they recline and
then there's nobody in front of them and
they're living the life of the life of
it that's what they get for getting the
first row I know I just I don't I really
don't like reclining and I know that
it's a hot take I do not like it okay
next the middle seat gets both arm rests
it's the consolation prize for being
squished between two people with nowhere
to lean case closed okay I agree I agree
but I just want to say from a financial
point of view like all three people
played the same yeah if middle seats
were cheaper right which they arguably
should be but and they're not I don't
know we all paid for this seat like we
all paid for one and a half arm rests
you know yeah I don't know if I agree
with that either I do I think I think
that they should be like shared yeah
I actually think the person in the aisle
no you know what the middle person gets
both the middle person gets both
headphones are a perfectly acceptable
conversation Ender overly chatty seat
mate headphones are a great way to keep
from being the sounding board for your
neighbor who can't take a hint agreed
agreed no and the person who's chatty
like they need to be spoken to 100 they
need to be escorted off the plane yeah
like that is not okay yes like okay in
the beginning you make a little chat
whatever for sure but if you're talking
to a stranger that you don't know the
entire time and like you know every now
and then two people who both want to
talk get seated next to each other and
that's beautiful and I love that for
them but most of the time it's a
torturer and a person who just wants
their piece of course and the torturer
can't read the room that's what I don't
understand like you can tell when
someone doesn't want to talk to you duh
they keep putting their airpod airpod
like back in the second you stop talking
yeah you're like oh they're like sorry
wait what'd you say like shut up yes
shut up shut the [__] up it's so true
okay by the way wasn't that interesting
that was interesting things when I asked
you if you had any stories thanks for
not bringing that up well wench I didn't
think of it but I did now but
sorry to your toasters is our weekly
advice segment we write in every
Wednesday
um we do three submissions they're from
deertoesters gmail.com and you can write
in about anything and it always stays
Anonymous don't worry Queens we've got
some some really [__] up [__] going on
today ready
first first submission hey girlies I am
desperate my longtime boyfriend of four
and a half years why I'm on track to get
married to just came home today with
four random horrible tattoos now he had
two other tattoos that he got while we
were dating that I approved of and I
liked them a lot but he did this on his
own randomly after work today he texted
me after he got them drawn up and thank
God I had my phone on me and I said
verbatim do not get them they are tacky
and they are ugly but he did it anyway
they're just so Pinterest board 2010
like cringe Boy tattoos I legit cried
when I saw them and we had a fight of
course this is making me question
everything now and I have to live with
looking at them every day I don't think
I can go through with marrying this man
that I love so dearly I really don't
think I can get over this and my ick is
guys with bad taste and Tattoos I need
your advice please send help PS they are
all eye themed maybe like evil eye I
guess that is like a little really
specific ick yeah I just want to say
this is like not a breakup deal breaking
but if it is like there's obviously
other thing like if for you this was
such a deal breaker like there's
something else like don't like him that
much yeah like that is annoying no it's
definitely rude like tattoos when you're
I don't know it's also so Random after
work to go get four yeah it's like a
crazy thing to do not like it's like oh
I was out with my buddies and I got one
but it's also um kind of nuts to
like if this was a girl and she got a
tattoo and the guy was like I don't want
you to get them he'd be like [__] off
[__] my body yeah but I don't know with
a guy it's like it's our body yeah you
know and that's definitely unreasonable
of me to say but a tattoo when you're in
a long-term relationship I do feel like
it's like our tattoo even for if a woman
were to get it too it's like do you
share that tattoo because you both have
to look at it right it's a family
decision yeah see I feel like Margo's
right like there's definitely something
about this relationship that you don't
like because you might be mad and pick a
fight and you'd be entitled to but to
like really want to break up with
someone like is kind of crazy yeah I'm
just feeling like there's something else
going on me too or like you needed a
reason you you needed a reason
no yeah I needed a reason why
x marks a spot where we fell apart he
poisoned the well I was lying in myself
literally the song is about you I knew
it from the first old-fashioned we were
sure you never had a shotgun shot at
that you don't like this man there's
something else going on you ever need a
getaway car you have an ick and I I
really I'm choosing to believe it
doesn't have a lot to do with the
tattoos like you are like put off by
this man and there's something else
going on in the relationship because
this is hella dramatic you're entitled
to be mad but like to want to break up
something something else and by the way
and maybe there that something else is
valid also no of course but you need to
you need to reflect yes you do you need
to look inward
sorry I know that's like the worst
advice anyone could give you but it's
time to reflect or maybe just think that
why is this bothering me so much
why is this bothering me so much all
right are you ready for our next one I
am hey turdy Lou and Jax I'm oh sorry
hey Trudy Lewin counts I'm currently
pregnant I am due mid July with our
second child my husband is a gamer and
he's very addicted to this one game
he'll play about 20 to 30 hours on a
weekly basis he has a full-time job and
he still manages to play that much I
asked him if he was going to take at
least a month off when baby number two
comes and he said no
he said he has quote commitments to
these people that he plays with and he
will call her family to help me after
the baby is born when he has to play we
have a two-year-old also who will need a
lot of attention as well am I crazy for
wanting him to take time off playing to
be involved and be available to help
with the two kids thanks for the advice
uh no no is he making money from gaming
even if he was like like seriously like
if he's making like money from gaming
and is like kind of like a job right and
it was like he's to support the family
like but he has another argument to be
made this is nuts no I just want to say
you were quite literally not crazy your
man needs to grow the [__] up grow the
[__] up no this is so not okay and the
fact that you already have a
two-year-old which means like you went
through the pregnancy birth and he
probably did this already girl girl you
should spill water like on his like PS4
or whatever no and like no you need to
sit this grown ass baby [__] down and
be like dude you're a dad yeah
you literally need to treat him like a
teenager like huh you need to throw away
the key lock up the cabinet and be like
no games for a month yeah ground him
like the fact that you really have to
require him and like beg him to do this
is really unacceptable and you you
actually need to have a serious
conversation with him because I feel
like getting commitments to these people
that's gonna just live around you have a
commitment
and wife no I feel like some people like
with gaming no it's crazy like it could
be a mental illness it's an addiction
yeah
it's an addiction no like he probably
thinks in game yeah and like dreams in
game yeah you know like you know when
you're reading a book that's like really
good and you like dream in the book yeah
that's like the craziest stuff no no
it's like you just are entranced into
this world yeah have you got any good
books lately oh no I like have been um
trying to start happy place by Emily
Henry I have such a hot and I just like
haven't been in like a reading mode but
I need to get back into it I have such a
hot take you don't like Emily Henry
Emily Henry is like not a good writer I
don't feel a certain way about her
honestly like I barely read any of her
books the only book I've read I think is
Beach read which I liked and then all
the other ones like you guys didn't like
like people on vacation was so bad Book
Lovers were so bad like the fact that
like she's just because of beach read
become one of those people but like
whenever she reads writes a book like I
never read it like why she she like they
could treat her like a Colleen Hoover
like or like an Ellen Hildebrand like no
yeah I I know that's like an extremely
hot take like I just don't think any of
her books are good sorry yeah I don't
have I really don't have an opinion on
her like I don't follow her career I
don't read her books I read Carly
Fortune's new book meet me at the liquor
it's not good it was fine I actually
think you would like it like it's not
life changing is it a sequel or just a
new book no it's just a new book and it
takes place in like the same region got
it of Canada okay I'll add that to my
list it's cute it's like not like read
it when you're not expecting anything
okay it's fine great she's like a decent
writer like I like her I like her too
and now I'm reading the new makeup
hunting wives girl oh she wrote do you
read hunting wives no
oh my God read that next I'm so jealous
of you it's the best book yeah it's like
literally perfect it's a perfect book oh
oh my God okay and now she has a new
book and it's good she likes to write
about like these like wealthy
neighborhoods in Texas which is just
always fun I love that we're like the
women are crazy and drink wine on a
quiet street yes of course did you like
it loved it so good recommended it to
everyone yes so good so good
um but I haven't read like an amazing
books recently what we're not going to
talk about it we're not going to talk
about the one that like actually ruined
my life and the book club
that Margaret made us watch it's really
so crazy how people can have such
different strong opinions and we're so
similar really like it kind of confuses
me like it boggles my mind do you read
any celebrity Memoirs ever no I feel
like I would maybe enjoy yeah but no
it's just like not my genre you should
read Josh Peck's book really I always
recommend it to people it's such an
underrated book like it's so interesting
like not only with the Nickelodeon being
a child start he talks a lot about like
the money he gets very specific but also
being like so fat and like how that
really [__] with him yeah and then how
he lost the weight but then also he went
through like a four-year addiction to
drugs like right he has a lot of
different chapters of his life and it's
extremely good I feel like it's the
perfect celebrity Memoir and I feel like
people don't talk about it enough okay
um and also on my list is I heard minky
Kelly's book Jackie told me Mickey
Kelly's oh I've been seeing that
everywhere yeah the whole clip about her
and um what's Taylor Kitsch oh what what
because they dated did they oh my God
yeah they dated during SNL during Friday
night and Friday Night Lights but he was
the one who was friends with the cast
and she wasn't
um so like it was really hard for her
and she they were on and off so like
when they were off and like broken up
she was like she was miserable she was
like I didn't have like my girlfriends
because everyone was like friends with
him oh my God but she like said like she
didn't actively try to be their friend
because she had him oh that's so
interesting yeah
um
let's talk about Tyler kitch just for
one second Taylor catch sure
what happened to him I don't know where
is he I don't know I think he's like
still in Texas he's so hot he should be
on Yellowstone
he should be on yellow one of the
spin-offs he should be on Yellowstone
1923. he should be on Yellowstone yeah
Yellowstone he should be on yeah duh duh
that's the best call you've ever made
thank you I feel very good about it okay
we went on a tangent but the final tier
toasters is brought to you by Lululemon
so Lululemon you guys know we're big
fans of but their shorts are really
something special they were made to
stretch flex and support the infinite
ways of working out giving you the
courage to LEAP into something totally
new and unexpected so a lot of their
shorts are really good the ones that we
like are the hottie hot short and the
Wonder train shorts so the hottie hot
short has a comfortable range of motion
and a flattering fit they allow you to
Max your stride so you can move freely
with confidence the lightweight fabric
lets in airflow so you can move without
the baggage they're designed to Wick
away sweat before you even notice that
it's there the Wonder train short are
really supportive in terms of stretch
and they also keep you dry so the
everluxe fabric manages heat and sweat
so you stay comfortable and focused so
it's sweat wicking quick dry material
um it absorbs moisture and Wick sweat
during the most intense training it's
just that time of year where we're all
having like crotch sweat yeah sweating
our crevices warm undercarriage swamp
ass whatever you want to call it under
carriage
undercarriage and it's important that
we're dressing whether we're working out
or just like going to the grocery store
it's that time of year where like you
just leave your house and like you're
sweating and it's just annoying to have
to come back and take a thousand showers
start dressing in Lululemon their shorts
are sweat wicking quick drying just
taking care of that the nether the warm
undercarriage area
it's a good way to describe it don't you
think you can get into Lululemon shorts
at lululemon.com you know we love all
the Lululemon products and shorts it's
that time of year counts can you believe
no I can't I had to shave my legs I was
really upset my legs
too um okay ready for our final and
third deer toasters
good morning girlies I'm a long time
listener love you dearly I don't even
know what kind of advice I need but
here's my situation this is my second
Mother's Day with my husband and our own
child we both have kids from previous
marriages or previous relationships
excuse me last Mother's Day I didn't do
anything like I had hoped nor did he get
me a card or a gift and gifts are really
My love language fast forward to this
year there's still no card and no gift
from him my daughter's dad helped her
get me a gift and she gifted it to me
that morning I was so thankful for that
my question is do I let this slide with
my husband or should I let him know how
I feel I hate to be a Naggy [__] wife
but this isn't the first offense and
last year I made him feel really really
bad about it and I thought maybe he
would learn his lesson but I guess not
sincerely a heartbroken and sad Mama
toaster oh I was gonna say like does he
know like she spoke to him about it last
year he still didn't do anything no it's
not okay like seriously that's and also
do you get him something for Father's
Day that's a good question not that it
really like matters because you it
shouldn't yeah like if you've said like
this is my love language like whatever
then he should obviously respect that
yeah you said something and I'm sorry
there's a special place to know for
people who don't respect mothers like
I'm sorry duh I'm sorry like it's really
not okay and it's really especially if
you didn't do anything last year the bar
is so low flowers a card whatever
happened to hello how are you like come
on yeah that's like really
unacceptable and I hate when you just
have to like ask for something that's so
like after something that's so very
minimum obvious and that it's like I
have to ask you to celebrate me it's
like embarrassing yeah I but you know
what you have to say it you have to say
because also it's just gonna keep going
and then it's gonna turn into just such
a resentment no so if you could try and
bite the bullet like as quickly as
possible Margo's right like this could
be one of those things that festers and
then like years down the road like you
find yourself bottling up all these
feelings and then you start yelling and
exploding and he's like what did I do
and like you don't really know but
you're really still mad about the first
Mother's Day you never got a gift and
every Mother's Day after that yes
communication is key one that's really
kind of the takeaway a lot of times from
your toasters communicado is
communicatos are you good communicator
counts I'm terrible are you mm-hmm
yeah you are yeah like if I'm feeling a
type of way No One's Gonna know about
anything until like it's like forced out
you will yeah that's like kind of like
your toxic trait no no I know and it's
like things like I would love to talk
about it but you don't know how I just
like can't
I can't do it why I just like can't get
it out you need to work on that counts
yeah well that's your toxic trait what's
mine
um where do I begin to be rude your
toxic trait this doesn't feel like a fun
game I know it feels like one of those
games that they play on housewives
before everyone starts killing each
other but now that I ask like I want to
know like what's my toxic trait
in terms of like being a good sister
friend wife you know yeah person
um toxic trait you really are great
thank you but like really you could say
it
um maybe just like
that you like expect and get like the
creme de La Creme of like anything okay
yeah no I'm definitely like a diva Diva
yeah but
but no not like Diva like mean Diva no
no I know I know it's just like but it's
like if we're at Stagecoach like you get
the nicest room yeah yeah yeah I mean I
did like find a book the house and I
thought that would be like a good way
for everyone to repay me
um and I was like you know under the
weather because of my z-pack so I
thought you know I thought I deserved it
I don't think I didn't think I I just
should get it because I wanted it I
thought I deserved it
like if you would book the house like
maybe you would have gotten the room
it's actually a really good
um answer that's definitely one of my
worst qualities like I just it's okay we
all have things like I need to be
comfortable yeah and but your level of
comfort is different than many others oh
I wanted to update everyone because I
was posting on social media last night
about getting dressed and staying alert
you know I'm doing this thing where I'm
trying to go out as much as I can on the
weekdays yes to see Taylor
um oh yes I did not see her I feel like
you guys would know if I do body attacks
in me I was like you want to meet me for
a drink Sam we can watch out my dinner
was wrapping up and I'm like she's not
here yet but like it's still kind of
early I had an early like business
dinner so I was like maybe tonight I'm
like should I like get another drink and
you'll come meet me and we'll just sit
and watch out of Britney Spears themed
how was your Broadway show you had such
a weird night it was so funny like I was
a show called it's called one more time
and it's all like um Britney Spears
songs but it's basically about like all
the Disney Princesses and how like they
are like
um what's a word let's put it out like
it's basically like what's wrong with
all of them it's like how Cinderella is
like um she wants more like right it's
like their toxic traits yeah it's like
Snow White like how it's like so [__]
up oh like that she like oh what did
they say that they just found her
sleeping in the in the woods and like
she was literally abused and like but we
take it as love wait they're like
pointing out all the flaws yeah and so
it's like they're trying to break free
out of the Disney Universe the princess
Universe oh that's cute
um it was funny I mean it's like we went
with Ryan and like he lived for it so it
took a perfect really it's a perfect
thing to go with like you should go with
Brian like like a gay night out like we
went it reminds me it sounds like we saw
n Juliet which you Ryan I would love and
you and Emily should go it's set to the
music of Max Martin legendary pop
producer of course Backstreet Boys he's
done Taylor he's done Brittany he's done
Cher he's done Celine Dion literally
everyone you would die
um and it's what happens if Romeo and
Juliet actually don't die got it and
it's all about Juliet and she like goes
to Paris and she like wants to be free
and it's actually a really to play like
in terms of like you know a
coming-of-age story yeah but the music
is so good and the girl I don't know how
much longer she's going to be on but the
girl who plays Juliet she was just on
the Kelly Clarkson show she was I swear
to God I never heard a voice like that
in my life oh my god really yeah what
about Jessica
it's up there with Jessica Voss she like
her big big moment at the end of the
show she sings Roar by Katy Perry and
it's chilling oh okay it's so good so
highly recommended for like for
something to do in the city um that's
our show kids today can't thank you
enough for filling in today of course
it's good to be here a pleasure it's a
pleasure do you know what that's from
that commercial in Israel
not commercial the hold music in Israel
oh yeah at the Tel Aviv Hilton it's a
pleasure doing business with you I'm so
glad you remember that
um I love you today early thank you so
much for listening to the Justin Morning
Show we did the fastest stories
available
and wickedly talented we are hope you
guys have an amazing Wednesday happy
hump day don't forget to hump someone
you love and we'll see you tomorrow bye
bye